عليكم من المكان الذي تدمر عدد من المنازل
التي تدمرت في جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم
وتحديدا
الكلاكله القبه شارع 15 عدد من المنازل
تدمر التماما
هنالك عدد من الضحايا وعدد من الاصابات تم
على اثرها نقل الى مستشفيات القرب من جنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم
تحدثوا الينا عن الاصابات وعن المنازل
التي تدمرت ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتاكد
تماما لماذا تم قصفه هذا المكان منطقه
الكلاكلات عموما منذ سلاحات الاشتباكات لم
تشهد اي مواجهات صراع عسكري بين قوات
الدعم السريع وقوات الشعب المسلحه حتى
هنالك عدد كبير من سكان وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم جائوا الفلاكله
بالاحتمال بهذا المكان لم يتاكد لنا مصادر
بان هذا القصف من اين تموت تم من الطيران
الحربي ولكن معظم الاهالي يقولون بانها
جاءت قصفات عشوائيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات